a story by fox business
facebook spent 23 million dollars on
mark zuckerberg's security in 2020
uh 23 million dollars on security for
ceo and found muscle
in 2020 fiscal year social media giant
disclosed last week facebook spent more
than 13.4 million dollars on personal
security for zuck at his residency
as it residences and during personal
travel zuck also received 10 million
dollar pre-tax allowance to cover
additional security equipment
and personnel for his family the
security costs rose slightly compared to
when facebook spent only 10.4 million as
well as 10 million allowance facebook
said zuckerberg is a unique position
because
negative sentiment regarding our company
is directly associated with them
23 million what do you think about i
don't think it sounds exorbitant at all
take a look at mark zuckerberg the guy
looks frazzled all the time
all the time i mean i have never seen a
picture of him or a video of him where
he looks calm cool
you know relaxed the number of threats
he must be facing
are astronomical if you think about
every celebrity is harassed on some
level the biggest ones are stalked and
their life's in danger
we just don't know sometimes you hear
about it but it's real
and i can only imagine what the
controversial stance is that facebook
takes and he
is facebook he is the face of it he is
he is the whole thing as much as
one person can be identified with a
brand as can possibly be
so i i don't think 23 million to protect
an investment
of trillion of a trillion dollars is
that exorbitant at all and i'll say this
what did seem high to me when i looked
at this story a little bit more in depth
is they spend six million dollars in
security
on cheryl sandberg to me that seems like
a hell of a lot of money to be spending
on
a lower level executive if you look at
the numbers for other
ceos of tech companies jack dorsey i
mean i think he's on
what i think it's around 3 million they
spend on him eric schmidt was 300k
when he was at google uh the ceo of
google or
when yeah the ceo of google now 1.2
million
so and tim cook is pretty low he's about
800 000 for his annual
security is what apple said so you know
there's just a lot of threats on him i
would imagine he travels a lot he you
know he has compounds in hawaii so
there's a lot of travel i i think a part
of it has to be linked to
hate it like you know hate it in most
potential future influence i combine
those two together so
tim cook does he hate it no no not
really does he have future influence of
wanting to go out and run for office i
don't know if tim cook's gonna run for
office right
okay you talk about uh cheryl sandberg
is she hated
yeah she's part of facebook is she
important without cheryl sandberg
they're not doing the kind of revenue
that they're doing so she's
very powerful on what she changed again
when she came from google and she
brought the algorithms
to facebook i had kenneth bombass on
okay i don't know if you remember two
months ago two and a half months ago
this guy's a uh bodyguard executive
protection
is what they do and the company is
called global threat solutions right and
he and i were speaking i said let me ask
you a question
he's represented clinton presidents
billionaires a bunch of different people
that he's represented okay
i asked him you know what is the life i
don't know if you guys remember when we
talk about the fact that
the bodyguards actually don't know how
to fight they know how to run great
bodyguards and
uh executive protection guys are great
runners they don't fight you they hit
and run it's what they do they don't sit
there and say you want to fight
they're not looking for eight degree
black belt they're looking for a guy
that can know how to leave the building
the fastest
that's their specialty pretty
interesting when you think about them
and take their
subject with them so you want a skinny
small executive protection guy that
knows how to fight defend
and leave is what they want to do we
also have the bodyguard with kevin
gossner there you go
okay so pretty much visualize that
versus the 6 8
300 that's not a that's not executive
that's the rapper's bodyguard that's a
show that's that's that's the show
like hopefully so i asked them i said
let me ask you a question if i want to
get
bodyguard you know i want to get your
service how much is it going to cost me
so what are you looking for
i said what if i want to have a couple
people full-time at my house all the
time one in the front one in the back
he says well you have to realize that's
three a day so what do you mean it's
three a day
sure he says it shifts it's eight hours
it's not only three a day
they can only work five days so you
really have three a day
so that's three times three is what
that's three times two is six
he says you know then six you gotta add
three more because the days they're off
they're working so you add
nine is what you got let's just say you
get so you do the math so the additional
two days is edition so that's 12
is what you're dealing with okay and he
said
camera everything to be there full
protection travel all that he says
you're looking at about three and a half
million dollars a year whoa
yeah so that's about three and a half i
said what'd you say it says three and a
half million dollars a year
i said three and a half he says yep it
says you got to calculate
around a thousand a dollar a day for a
real good one
so a thou a day times three times
he's doing a whole calculation you're
looking at two and a half to three and a
half million dollar year yeah so
regular billionaires are getting two
million dollars to three and a half
million dollars for body card service
for something like this
32 million for zuck 23 million dollars
for zuck i think it's a deal i think
it's a steal
that's also if you only have one
bodyguard we can't hear you raise this
volume please i can barely hear
them go ahead that's only if you have
one bodyguard at a time yep like
three that's right yeah so now imagine
you have two or three
and like one of them is a driver now
you're traveling
exactly car restaurants that's
constantly and then also a big thing
that that was in the story is that
last year what happened last year pretty
controversial year in many ways it's
election year
imagine the money they get spent on
facebook to sway ads either way
and him and i mean he's he was probably
one of the biggest ones in the hot seat
for
things that they allowed things that
they fact checked this that and the
other
so i mean it makes sense that it goes up
by the way they voted bo jackson has a
better athlete
yeah i thought so well anyway this this
uh we got some stats for you
um yeah on mark zuckerberg this is it
comes out to 2 million dollars a month
about 65 grand a day
uh but you talked about being a
controversial figure and how much is
home cost and approval man
you know obviously he's worth over 100
billion dollars at this point
let's just talk about favorable and
unfavorable ratings facebook's favorable
rating
43 unfavorable rating 47 percent
okay so more i'm surprised it's not
higher unfavorable right yeah i'm
surprised
let me keep going mark zuckerberg's
favorable rating 20
unfavorable 56 percent to put it in
perspective
trump's favorable rating was 40 50 56
unfavorable keep going zuck does he have
too much power
power 73 say yes 41
say that that zuck should resign the
only ceo
in the country the only tech ceo in the
country that has an actual
positive net approval rating is your
friend tim cook 23
favorable 18 unfavorable just a couple
more
stats for you does facebook have too
much power 69
said yes and then um
last at does 57 believe facebook is
primarily a harm to
society and 71 believe the company
prioritizes profits even if it causes
societal harm
you know if you if not good ratings for
our friends of three million dollars for
yourself
these other guys are lying jack dorsey's
their their numbers that are lying what
did jack dorsey
they said it was like uh
79 000. out of your mind i know i know
and literally that's what they said for
eric schmidt 300k and 1.2 well the only
reason why i would believe a 79 000 is
if you live in the office and you never
leave
and you have to count the company's
security as personal security right
you have to have security exactly the
amount of money they invested in twitter
security in the building you know how
much money they probably put into
security cameras
key cards all of that you know how much
that cost that's a massive ticket right
there
so no i don't think he's spending 79 000
and 20.
we just learned that people really
really don't like zuck
and they really don't like facebook but
so zuck the human robot
well why though think about why here's
what i want you to think about we just
talked about the rock running because
he's got 220 million instagram followers
zuck running he's got two and a half
billion followers yeah
if zach zuck is the the only guy if you
think about that if he runs
he can be the new world order leader if
you actually think about it because he's
got
world global influence give him any
ideas
interesting you did the art the
interview with medicovin he said that
these tech companies
virtual government virtual governments
that was pretty profound statement right
there
they're becoming virtual governments is
what they're becoming so if you enjoyed
this little short segment from the
podcast that we did here's another short
segment to watch or if you want to see
the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye